el fiscal general de Washington col
Racing demandó a los olds y a los
organizaciones Insurgentes que se
tomaron el Capitolio por los altos daños
económicos causados en la capital
estadounidense Esta es la tercera
demanda que reciben estos grupos tras el
atentado del 6 de enero contra el
Capitolio precisamente el objetivo de la
demanda es usar una ley que congeló la
financiación del Club Cruz clan en su
momento para imponer grandes penalidades
financieras a estas organizaciones de
extrema derecha que según el fiscal
fueron responsables de la toma al
Capitolio se estima que las penalidades
a pagar de estas organizaciones estarían
entre los 9 millones de dólares que
ayudarían a pagar las reparaciones en
las que la ciudad tuvo que incurrir pero
no para pagar los costos de salud de los
oficiales de policía heridos tratando de
proteger el edificio del legislativo
cabe mencionar que hoy la cámara de
representantes votará acusar de desacato
a markevirus ex jefe del gabinete de
Donald Trump quien dejó de cooperar con
la investigación aquí adelantaba el
comité del Congreso que Investiga
precisamente los atentados al Capitolio
del 6 de enero miros ya había revelado
como periodistas de Fox news
congresistas y familiares y habían
pedido a Trump en su momento que parara
el ataque estos mismos después lo
defendieron